hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well towards the end
of Nicomachean ethics board six
Aristotle is going to discuss for us a
very interesting topic which certainly
fills in some gaps in his moral theory
in what we typically observe what we
might call his philosophical
anthropology is theories of human nature
and what this topic is has to do with
virtue but virtue that is certainly
natural to the human being or even that
needs you to certain animals other than
human beings as he suggests there this
is the the topic of the natural virtues
virtues that we would have in us by
nature who seek a poverty in the
singular or the singular that's sort of
encompassing the whole of it now we want
to remind ourselves of what Aristotle
said in the very beginning of the neck
of McCann ethics that in a book to that
we don't actually have virtue in us by
nature virtue is
and acquired property or quality is to
you know if we're going to be very
technical about it it is a hexxus it is
a estimate into something that is
established within us through multiple
repeated actions of a certain sort and
ever going to see it's not just enough
to just do those sorts of actions over
and over again there is some requirement
that there be some practical reasoning
or some intelligence involved some
deliberate moral choice so to sing that
virtue could in some way be natural
going beyond the fact that we have a
capacity for it that seems to be going
against what Aristotle has been telling
us all along so we should wonder about
you know how this would actually work he
says that everybody agrees that there
are certain qualities that are there in
us in a certain way that are you know so
to speak virtue us or we might say even
virtue like or virtue way and that that
in a certain way that Hosts is very
important that is weakening this this
framework it's not saying they're
exactly the same thing as virtues in us
some people are just born to be just or
born to be temperate or born as
courageous that post supplies all of the
examples that he gives and he gives you
quite a few of them you know we do talk
about children as having a sort of
natural sense of justice although it's a
pretty fallible one all you got to do is
to put a kid in slightly wrong
circumstances and it's not going to be
relied upon to see through good moral
action likewise some kids are more prone
to something like courage other kids are
more prone to something like cowardice
but they're not truly courageous or
cowards or even rash fool-hearty until
they become older become adults have the
Faculty of reason operative and can
gage the immoral choice in the full
sense of the term
likewise temperance some kids are you
know easy to you know sort keep control
over their appetites other kids have a
very very hard time with that and we
could go down the list of all these
different virtues some kids are
naturally more friend-like with other
kids some kids tend to be more emotional
some other kids tend to be more truthful
some kids are more generous some kids
are just obsessed with social standing
and on their and you know swing to one
extreme or to another extreme and don't
have right ambition every one of the
virtues that Aristotle discusses we can
see as in us in a sort of nascent state
from our childhood up and so Aristotle
says that children and even animals if
you read some of his works in which he's
discussing animals he doesn't call what
they yeah virtue but they do have to
determinate dispositions which express
one thing rather than another so you
know some animals are very clever other
animals are very courageous other
animals have other qualities but they're
not virtues in in the full sense they
they are natural dispositions they are
you know
hexxus who seek a degree but they're not
quite the same thing as virtue one index
of this is that these can be quite
harmful when they're lacking what he
calls in this case is using this a very
broad sense mind or noose why do I say
he's using it in a very broad sense
because a little bit later he's going to
talk about our need for phronesis
so he doesn't mean noose just in the
sense of the intellectual virtue of
noose or understand
or intellect he means that unless we
actually have developed the rational
part of our soul which children you know
they're not to blame for the fact that
they haven't developed that it's not
quite active yet it is in the process of
development the animals not to blame
that they don't have that because that's
their nature right they weren't born
with that capacity to be fully rational
but when we're not fully rational then
these things like the natural virtues
these natural dispositions and we might
praise people for you know we we see a
kid being generous we praise them
they're generous with the wrong person
and they give away their you know
inadvertently their personal information
and get stalked as a result now not so
good right yeah you know the kid is
often quite confused about this hey I
thought you said it was good for me
today you know be nice to people all the
time and they said look you gotta you
kind of temper that a bit you need some
common sense is usually what we say but
what we're really thinking the kid needs
is a good dose of phronesis
a good dose of practical wisdom and of
course from an Aristotelian perspective
we're really expecting a bit too much
out of the child to to have that as a
matter of fact probably a lot of
shouting and criticism that we give to
kids for lacking phronesis
probably helps to steer some of them
away from developing Croesus and maybe a
sign of a lack of her basis on our own
part kids are going to do things partly
right and also screw up this is
Aristotle's perspective on it he does
not have high expectations for children
so these can be like it whitter quite
harmful went when lacking mind any of
the the Virg
justise generosity courage good humor
all these can can go astray when we're
not using our intellect this is another
reason why virtue is not simply a matter
of having habits or dispositions it is
one that involves us understanding what
we're doing and choosing it as part of
our character the child is not yet at
that point although they they can get
further and further along the spectrum
so Aristotle is going to say that the
natural virtues just resemble they have
the kind of home oil kind of similarity
a kind of lightness to the moral virtues
but they're not actually the moral
virtues so we want to be very clear in
distinguishing these apart from each
other but also recognizing that these
can kind of feed into each other that
when we see for example a child being
generous we do want to encourage him or
her in their generosity because once we
do add mind to an intellect and they
have a better sense about it they're a
little bit further along than some kid
who is naturally stingy or naturally
prodigal likewise a kid who already has
a good disposition with respect to anger
we want to try to encourage that and
eventually steer that into being the
actual virtue of mildness or good temper
same thing with courage same thing with
temperance we want to make use of the
natural capacities that are already
there and provide them with a better
framework within which they make more
sense once they're integrated into the
framework of intellect and choice they
can become full verges Aristotle a she
says it a couple points that certain
responses that we have certain emotional
responses kind of function in the same
way so righteous indignation our nemesis
can you know steer the right way becomes
something like justice you know the kind
of anger that we feel when we're being
threatened or when we see say our
children threatened can be rightly
steered into something that would in
fact be genuine courage we can we can do
this with with other things so this is
this is a very important point the last
part of this that we want to say is that
Aristotle draws from this the conclusion
that the virtues do in fact require some
development of prudence not just
intellect intellectual capacities but
prudence the capacity to figure out what
the right means are within determinate
situations to steer the the reasoning
process towards what is actually good in
the different modalities of goodness for
human beings and to figure out how to
get ourselves towards our ultimate
ethics